my guest tonight is a very funny
comedian who hosts the podcast
beautiful anonymous which is streaming
now
on topic and all topic channels
i really do like this guy please welcome
our good friend chris
gethard chris so good to see you you too
that's really nice that you said you
like me i like you too well it was on
the card i had to read it
i that's not true i did add that part
myself because i do
really like you uh you're very funny guy
and
um i've gotten to know you pretty well
over the years coming on my show
now we're in these very strange
circumstances uh
you look to be in um i'm just judging by
your background
a beautiful small looks like a new
england
cottage that you're staying in it's
actually in new jersey
um but thank you so much yeah it makes
it considerably less quaint
that i say new jersey instead of new
england but yeah it really does
it really does you know no one says oh
boy i do really want that
new jersey chowder right now you know
what i mean
no most people are like what is this
hellscape where you fly into the newark
airport and the sky is literally
shooting flames
what is what is going on uh now chris
there's a lot to catch up on here
because i
you said something the last time we
spoke that stuck with me now i talked to
a lot of people
and i talked to him and the minute i'm
done talking to them i immediately
forget what they said but you said
something that stuck with me which is
that you had started going on cameo
cameo of course the service
where a celebrity can go on and give a
quick message to somebody and make
uh usually like a smaller amount of
money but
but you've been doing that and
that stuck with me because i thought i
haven't talked to anybody
who's doing cameos so i i want to sort
of catch up on that
how's it going are you still doing or
did you abandon cameo
i thought long and i i i want to abandon
cameo i find it to be weird
but it's also a nice way to make small
amounts of money
now that i can't tour and go on the road
so i i do it if you remember
last time specifically there was this
one guy named randy yes randy yeah
yeah he had caught covid and then i was
making a lot of money
because his friends were buying cameos
from me to wish him well
tell him to get better and you
accurately pointed out that maybe that's
not
cool to monetarily exploit a sick man
yes
conan since then since my last
appearance this guy's become a
cash cow he got electrocuted i made a
lot of money when that happened wait
wait a minute so he got better he got
better from kovid he recovered from
kovid
but then got electrocuted yeah i was
sitting there like man this
i guess this well is dried up and then
no he uh he touched a loose wire in the
back of a u-haul truck and electrocuted
his hands
he burned his hands i got i got coined
for that
then he moved to northern michigan and i
guess when he hit the cold his hands
were having all these pains he found out
that he had
broken bones from when he was a teenager
and they hadn't healed right so he has
to get surgery on his hands
cha-ching and then
i just saw on instagram i followed the
guy on instagram the other day this i
thought was just truly insane randy if
you're watching
i am serious he put a post on instagram
conan he bought a boat
it's a picture i'm standing in front of
a boat i'm like randy with your luck
take that boat and push it into the
ocean with your broken burnt hands and
never
think about it again man like you're bad
luck
johnny to the court don't get on a boat
and i stand to financially gain
a lot if he has a boating accident yes i
don't that's a lot of money anymore
i don't want any more of randy's pain
money i don't want anymore well
wait a minute of course you say you
don't want it but you're not turning it
down
and you've referred to him several times
you you
describe one of his horrible injuries
and then you start
laughing and you call him a cash cow
so don't tell me that you oh i can't
take any more of his money
look if we're living in the awful stages
of late-game
capitalism right and if uh the guy who
owns amazon can make 13
billion dollars in a day then i can make
35 dollars when this guy randy
electrocutes his hands is that the
amount of money that you get
uh when you're on cameo is it 30 is is
that what you get 35
a pop they take a cut so i get like 28
and i've been on tv a bunch of times i'm
getting 28 dollars a pop on these weird
videos of my
awful pale head uh my um
my wife has all these friends back from
she's from seattle and she has these
friends
that are very sharp uh they're witty and
they're sharp
and we were hanging around in seattle
before covid this is like a little over
a year ago
and we were having uh drinks uh
and someone was talking about cameo
and how they got like the kid from
different strokes to wish him a happy
birthday
and uh they said how much money it was
and i said
do you think uh when do you think's the
time for me to go on cameo and
uh one of her friends looked at me and
he said three years ago
wow nailed it nailed it
i think he's actually six years ago but
uh
um you know you you bring up a good
point which is
you're on cameo you're making this money
chris you've been
very successful uh you have really made
a name for yourself you're very well
respected uh comedic performer and
a very funny and an agile mind
yet i find this tragic when
you search your name on audible and
you've done you know you're a big
st you're a big name when you search
your name on audible
only porn comes up yeah only
porn yeah look at this this is
right here we have older [ __ ]
banged hard um
hard as it gets this has to do with your
last name is that right
yeah i mean i think i think maybe the
first time we met
we we got a good laugh out of the fact
that my last name
does spell out the words get hard that's
just a true
sad fact about my life so when you
search my name on audible yeah the
number one search result is older [ __ ]
gets banked hard because get
and heart are both in there but the
thing that makes me really sad
because i've been hearing that joke
since middle school yeah i can get used
to that the thing that makes me really
sad is i've written
three books and that
like i wish that was at least number
four you know
yeah i wish older [ __ ] gets bengaard
came in
after my actual written works i don't
even think i'm in the top five
of books that come up when you search
gethered it's all pornography
right it does occur to me that if you
did porn
your name would be at the top talk about
a cash cow
right there yeah because your name is
get hard and then you could put get hard
in the title
and you know i'm sure
i bet there's tons of people watching
right now looking at this going
yeah let's make that happen i really
want this guy to segue into a
pornography career
don't put it down i'm listen chris
i am also pigment challenged i'm a very
pale sickly person
i tried it like in the 80s for a year or
two
and uh yeah didn't go well but it didn't
go
horribly is there any parody porn about
you
that's a big thing parody porn right uh
yeah i don't know that there is i mean
let's put that out there again to the
to the viewers if uh if anyone out there
knows of any conan
with bonen monnin um you know
please don't make me do the work for you
let's just find if it's out there
cause i want my cut talk about cha-ching
they
they owe me a piece you know if not if
they find some super tall redhead guy
who looks like you
and they give him a sidekick and they
name him the sidekick like randy ichter
and then they start that that that would
be that would be amazing
would you would you watch it yes i would
yes i would
i would watch it repeatedly i'd watch it
long after
um people could even think that it was i
was doing it ironically
they would just become clear that i was
addicted to that pornography
you're living in new jersey now yeah
what are you doing
you know you've got this suburban life
in new jersey
and uh you can't tour because of covid
what are you doing mostly lawn
maintenance i've become really obsessed
with lawn care
in a genuine way i tend to fall into
tracks where
when i get into something i get
extremely ocd about it and
i've become like a huge lawn head i
don't know how into lawns you are
so if i'm saying anything not at all not
at all what do you mean i'm a huge lawn
head no one says i'm a lawn head
i am a massive lawn head massive lawn
head
it started i cut my grass too short and
i got the crab grass and then all my
neighbors were making fun of me they're
saying that
that's a rookie mistake so i went on
this quest to fix my lawn i have a whole
chart of dates when i have to put down
fertilizers
and i'm not trying to act like a big
shot but i spent a couple extra bucks i
got the jonathan green products the the
grassy
blend i got the jonathan green ultra
black beauty which is a mix of kentucky
bluegrass and
say it with me conan tall fescue tall
fescue i was gonna
you got there first but i was gonna i
was gonna say tall fescue but you got
there first
do you know where else that grows oh
yeah south lawn of the white house
you bad the same grass as the white
house hey longhead's talking right here
don't get me started on lawns cause i'm
counting them days
march 15th is when i put my next round
of green up fertilizer i like count down
the days i checked the calendar
and also it was only like six years ago
that vice magazine called me the king of
underground comedy in the future of late
night television yeah
and so this is what i do this is what
you do now
um well it doesn't mean that vice
magazine was wrong
it just means i went seriously australia
you went astray you want to stray it's
your fault does the lawn look good are
you proud of it
uh half of it looks good and the other
half of it looks completely horrific in
a way that fills me with genuine shame
also cars and trucks keep driving along
the edge of it on the road and then it
pools with this like nasty
um standing muddy water and i can't tell
you how much it fills me with genuine
anxiety and
self-doubt and self-hatred and i have no
i have real mental issues so i don't
toss those phrases around lightly
i'm submitting this entire interview
immediately for a peabody award
um i think we're gonna i think the fact
that we went
from porn to lawn maintenance
yeah what other show can do that what
other host guest combination
can do that that's only us chris
absolutely and you dug so deep that you
got me to admit i have anxiety which
i've never
no one's ever who would think that who
would who would think you've struggled
in any way
with anxiety hey guys whose last name
leads to older
[Laughter]
that are can seem random you know i have
obsessions with you know presidential
uh arcane knowledge and weird historical
facts
i have a lot of other obsessions as well
we don't have to get into all that now
your obsession uh is of obscure
sodas obscure like soda pop
yeah that is very difficult to find so
we're not talking about your a w root
beer we're not talking about
coca-colas and things like that we're
not even talking about um
mountain dew or anything like that we're
talking about sodas that most people
haven't heard of
yeah yeah i stopped drinking 20 years
ago and i got addicted to soda instead
and there's some great ones out there um
mr cucumber is probably my favorite
that's what are you talking about
there's one called mr cucumber
it's spelled mister and then q cumber
and it's absolutely
if you taste this stuff you're gonna go
i don't need to drink anything else in
my entire life this cucumber flavored
soda is nailing it it's the best where
do you work in one procure
mr cucumber nowhere in the northeast
really which is unfortunate to me i have
to drive this
almost to albany is the nearest store i
know if that has it
in new jersey it's like a three and a
half hour drive i can't order it on the
internet in la there's a store called
galco's that has
every great soda they're amazing um the
one i've never had that even they don't
have
is there's this drink it's not actually
a soda it's called delaware punch
it's it's not carbonated but it's very
rare
and it was it started in 1913 it got
super
super popular and coke bought it shut it
down they would do that shut down their
competitors
right and uh i found it they they still
make it in a couple counties in
louisiana because it was really popular
there
i was doing shows in new orleans i
walked around in the new orleans
humidity heat
all day spent hours going different
stores finally found it drank it
did not like it i did not find it good
but what a sad quest it ends with no i
really don't like this why don't you
like
what is it called delaware delaware
punch delaware punch it was very syrupy
i found it very syrupy but that's
not even the saddest part the saddest
part is i later found out
that the stuff you can find america in
america it's not the right it's not the
original formula
the original formula had a type of food
coloring that has since been
outlawed by the fda so then i was
researching it more
and i found out that there's a bottling
plant in guatemala
that still uses the original food
coloring so
before covid i legitimately was planning
to fly to guatemala
just to track down a bottle of this
stuff
which i want to be clear is a drink i
already know
i do not like i'm just that much of a
completist
that i felt like i had to have it
food coloring will not affect the taste
only the color
maybe so rate this for me what is the
bigger waste of your life
a lot of time on lawn maintenance that
gets you
only a half decent lawn or quests
to find and track down worldwide sodas
that you don't like
i mean what a question what an
eye-opening and revealing question that
illuminates everything about my
priorities why my career has headed in
the direction it has
so many things why i'm plagued with a uh
just an
uh a sense of low level loneliness that
never leaves me all these things are
becoming very clear yeah
i think you just added a pulitzer to
that peabody yeah
no no trust me um i'm submitting this
interview for every award that's out
there
every award yeah uh every single award
we're gonna get a latin grammy for this
emmy
i promise you can't wait yeah i cannot
wait very exciting
yeah it's hard to say it's hard to say
which is a bigger waste of time
um and i i i kind of feel like i need to
pass on the answer because if i analyze
it too much more i'm going to get
so sad yeah yeah and you're alone right
now and you're in this
beautiful new england home that's been
misplaced in new jersey so i don't want
you to be
sad um let's what is your favorite
uh of the conventional sodas that i
could get
right now i'm in los angeles in an
abandoned theater but that i could get
what's your favorite of the conventional
sodas so that
do you like anything that's that someone
could buy
yeah yeah i do like mountain dew i like
wild cherry pepsi i think it's become
much easier to find mexican coke now yes
it has
cane sugar instead it has cane sugar and
real cocaine in it
it does it's it has a load of cocaine it
gets you really hopped up and then
also if you wait um until passover if
you ever see coca-cola with a yellow cap
that has cane sugar so that's a fun
i think that's what it doesn't seem like
you're finding as much fun in that
as i am no no i'm i i respect
uh the the laws of the orthodox jewish
people
yeah and and that they need so no i
would never
i i just was solemnly nodding that i'm
glad that i
i feel like you're not sharing my giddy
excitement though and that
there's like i think if you and i over
coke if you and i are giddy at the same
time it's too much raw energy
so we need to keep it at this level
right here that's why
now tell me about podcast the podcast
beautiful anonymous i want to
congratulate you because
it has become a tv show that's very rare
that uh i mean a podcast has to be
quite good to then become a tv show yeah
i'm really proud of it i mean that shows
changed my life i just talk to people on
the phone and connect with them and they
tell me like
sometimes funny stuff sometimes super
sad stuff but it's all about human
connection and
the fact that it got turned into a tv
show when it's based on me talking to
anonymous people on the phone i'm like
that's
that's amazing that someone took a
chance on it and
really proud of it i'm really proud of
it i talked to a woman a few weeks ago
on the show who identified as a pirate
that was fun
she views herself as a pirate different
people can identify with a number of
different genders this person identifies
as a pirate
yeah on the weekend she dresses up as a
pirate and she hangs out with her pirate
crew
they don't have a boat they just dress
up as pirates that hang out
and they all have assigned roles on the
ship and then she has a captain
and she told me that if they're all
going to eat and like everybody votes
for tgi fridays but then the captain
wants to go to chili's they go to
chili's he's the captain
yeah she says she kind of views herself
more as a pirate and the rest of her
life
is the is the fake version and her real
life is being a pirate here's what we're
finding out through
i think it's one of the beauties of
podcasts is yeah i think there's a
million of them
[Music]
in the united states that number's
growing all the time
everybody has their own unique
expression
and they can always people can put
something out there and then you'll
there'll be people that come
and say yeah me too pirate my life is
all about being a pirate
it's amazing way for people to connect
it really is and and
i'll tell you for the ridiculous stuff
that's that's really true but then even
the series people have called up and
told me
he told stories where you're like that
is one in a million it's heartbreaking
it's that and invariably someone on the
internet will go oh my god
this made me feel so much better because
i have my own version of it and i'm
going
you sit there you go every person who
i've ever been mad at for taking too
long at the atm machine in front of me
like
they might have been getting ransom
money for a kidnapping like i have no
idea why
this person like there's it's really
changed my perspective and like i spend
so much time getting angry at people and
then my job has become talking to people
and i realized
everyone's life is stressful on some
level
and they're living in that at every
moment so it's taught me to chill out
take it easy on people the other thing
you should take away from that is that
it's another way
in addition to cameo to make money
extorting money from
people uh yeah tricking them into
thinking that
you have a loved one and you then you
need the cash quickly
it's just another way to go yeah and as
you say i thought where you were going
to go is saying you know people will
call up and share their painful stories
with me and it is
another way that i have managed to
monetize other people's pain which i
didn't even realize until halfway
through this interview but
i may be evil i might be evil oh well
i've
looked you up you're a bad guy it says i
looked it up yeah you're on
when you searched my name that's what
came up now well there's a lot of porn
and i had to watch it all uh
but then bad guy came up at the end you
also have i want to mention this you
have a new podcast about your love of
new jersey
because you are you're you love all
things
jersey yes i do i i mean i grew up here
i've always been
a fierce defender of it it gets made fun
of a lot but i think that really
i think that's why the art that comes
out of here is as good as it is because
everybody doubts us so that's how you
get a springsteen is when everybody's
telling you you're not supposed to make
it
right i love it and we're making this
new podcast where we like explore how
ridiculous it is and i do it my
buddies from high school and on the mo
here's a sentence i think you will love
on the most recent episode it was about
pollution
and my friend bonaduce was talking about
how he was hired to help clean up a
toxic waste site
and he took a poop on the ground and an
epa inspector accidentally stepped in it
like if that won't get you to at least
give this one listen
i don't know what else what wanna do she
a poop on the ground some epa nerd
stepped in it
yes new jersey's the best it does yeah
only in new jersey right
i mean not too many other places he said
the guy walked up to him and goes hey
man
he didn't know the guy was a scientist
on the job this random lunatic walks up
to him in the woods goes hey man
you see any uh snakes or turtles around
here and bonaduce's response was you
[ __ ] we're in the woods there's
snakes everywhere
and then the guy went looking for snakes
and bonaduce you're out there on a work
site you're working construction
sometimes you got to go and there's no
bucket around
the guy slipped in a bonnet dooch's
poopy it happens
you know that's you know what that's
bonaduce for you
you know oh i mean that's high school
you know what that is
that is classic bonaduce endless pure
bonaduce to the core you have no idea
it's the best there's a whole book just
in bonaduce but if you write it
and i go to look it up i'm just gonna
see a lot of
it'll come up as banacooch uh beautiful
anonymous is streaming
now on topic and all topic channels you
can listen to chris's podcast
new jersey is the world
wherever you get your podcast and
that's a podcast that has prime
bonadooch
uh stories you guys you gotta get those
uh chris always a pleasure talking to
you
don't be sad be happy and um i'm gonna
find you that missing soda that you've
never had i'll go to guatemala i'll get
i'll do a travel show where i go to
guatemala in search of that soda
if you ever do i will can i tag along on
my own dime please
absolutely not
no no
you get it i need a wingman i'm out
there traveling the world
ladies you know you know what i mean
bonadooch can come you know what i mean
that's a wingman
you'd be you'd be much safer in his uh
his world-weary construction worker
hands i promise you that
yes of course you and i will find that
soda together
uh chris gether thank you very much a
pleasure thanks for having me